Here the correct answers are negative five thirds and positive one third. Great
work if you found these two. I know fractions aren't always the easiest to work
with but let's see how we got these two answers. FIrst we'll let u equal x plus
one. This will allow us to perform the u substitution in this step so we'll
have 9 u squared mini s6 u minus 8 equals zero... Now that we have a quadratic
expression, we want to find factors of negative 72, the A times the C, that sum
to negative 6 are B value. Those factors are negative 12 and positive 6. So, I
use these two to rewrite the middle term here. We use factoring by grouping to
get 3u plus 2 times 3u minus 4 equals to 0. We set each of these factors equal
to 0 so we'll have u can equal negative two thirds or u can equal positive four
thirds. Now if you got this far and solved for these values of u great work,
keep in mind though we need to solve for the values of x, the original variable
from our equation. We use our two solutions for u, and the fact that u equals x
plus 1, to solve for the original variable x. So, we'll have x plus 1 equals
negative two thirds, and we'll have x plus 1 equals to four thirds. We subtract
1 from each side of the two equations to get these statements. Here, we have x
equal to negative two thirds minus 1. So,since I have negative two thirds and
negative 1, I have negative 1 and thirds. This is the mixed number. If I change
it to an improper fraction, I'd have negative five thirds. For the other value
of x, we'll have x equals four thirds minus 1. When I subtract 1, I get to
choose what this 1 looks like. Since I have thirds over here, I want to make
sure that I subtract three thirds, a form of 1, over here. Four thirds minus
three thirds equals one third, and here are our two solutions: negative five
thirds and one third.